hellemmes nos politiques
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdo
politique sur radio sensations votre
rendez vous politique du dimanche ou en
association avec tv 78 épisodes 197
notre invité ce soir et véronique
matillon les politiques
véronique matillon bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes maire de rambouillet
vice-présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération rambouillet territoire
en charge de l'action sociale et de la
santé mais vous êtes également
infirmière et première vice présidente
de l'union des maires des yvelines
votre ville a été au coeur de
l'actualité ces dernières semaines avec
le décès d'une fonctionnaire de police
de 49 ans le 23 avril mais aussi la mort
d'un jeune sapeur-pompier de 19 ans dans
un accident de moto alors que ce dernier
se rendait à l'enterrement de stéphanie
m
c'est votre premier mandat en tant que
maire comment vivez vous ces semaine de
deuil
alors oui c'est mon premier mandat en
tant que maire et je pense que on n'est
jamais préparé en tant que maire à vivre
de tels instants forcément difficile de
vivre des moments aussi compliqué on les
voit à la télévision on les voit sur
d'autres villes
on ne sait jamais dit à rambouillet
qu'il était exclu que ça se passe j'en
veux pour preuve tous le toutes les
installations qui ont été faites à la
mise en place du plan vigipirate
mais petit à petit on se dit voilà on
espère que ça ça n'arrivera pas on n'y
pense pas tous les jours
et puis il y a le coup de téléphone qui
arrive sur lequel au départ évidemment
on émet des doutes et mais on se rend
sur la les lieux la réalité là et en
tant que maire et bien c'est
d'accompagner bien entendu tout d'abord
les fonctionnaires de police sur place
et et les aider à passer ce choc qui à
être présent à des moments cruciaux est
très compliqué pour eux et puis aussi
être très de rambolitains et de la
population parce qu un maire doit être
présent doit se être rassurant et et
puis soutenir soutenir tout le monde et
la famille de la fonctionnaire de police
et les policiers et les rambolitains
donc voilà c'est ce sont des moments qui
sont assez particulier et puis en effet
l'accident concomitant de ce jeune
sapeur-pompier un jeune dont on ne
parlait pas et qui était très investi
faisait beaucoup pour les autres un
véritable à cet altruisme et dont on a
célébré les obsèques hier donc deux
événements consécutifs qui ne sont pas
du tout de la même nature mais qui
endeuillent très fortement la ville
surtout que la ville de rambouillet une
ville où nous nous rendons compte à quel
point nous sommes en famille entre tous
les partenaires à la fois bien sûr parce
que notre police municipale travaille
beaucoup avec la police nationale mais
aussi avec les secours n'est aussi avec
le smur parce que dans tous ces
événements il faut aussi ne pas oublier
tous ces services de secours qui sont
intervenus et les équipes du smur qui
sont intervenus et qui en effet sont
habituels et sur des des accidents des
des choses difficiles à vivre
mais lorsqu'il s'agit d'un attentat il y
a une autre dimension
et lorsqu'il s'agit d'intervenir sur un
accident ou une personne avec laquelle
on a l'habitude de travailler est
impliqué
et malheureusement décède oui c'est
compliqué pour eux alors concernant
l'attaqué au couteau du commissariat de
rambouillet comment une telle attaque
est elle possible
et bien la preuve qu'elle est possible
en fait c'est toute la difficulté
d'avoir des des lieux qui représentent
des valeurs républicaines et qui sont la
cible parce qu'il ne faut pas s'y
tromper la cible n'était pas la ville de
rambouillet elle était bien une atteinte
à un symbole de la république il est
toujours difficile d'avoir des des lieux
d'accueil dès lors que l'on accueille du
public
on le sait il y à des risques il y à des
risques d'avoir des personnes qui
entrent et qui peuvent tout à fait
entrer de façon normale et est
finalement s'avérer dangereuse là il y
avait pourtant quand même un sas est
bien la preuve que même un ça ce n'est
pas suffisant pour ralentir des volontés
l' enquête est en cours moi je ne peux
rien dire sur tous les modes opératoires
qui se sont qui ont amené cet individu à
intervenir sur ce commissariat
aujourd'hui oui nous sommes encore dans
le deuil
les questionnements ça n'est pas
forcément à nous alors pas nous ville de
nous les poser sur le commissariat parce
que c'est un établissement de l'état
mais de les accompagner et nous serons
toujours là au maximum pour les protéger
et puis aussi protéger tous les
bâtiments qui peuvent être impliqués
vous aimeriez justement qu'il ait des
mesures pour renforcer les commissariats
il faut des mesures de toute façon déjà
pour renforcer l'image de la police
l'image de nos forces de l'ordre parce
que elles sont la cible de beaucoup de
critiques
mais on oublie qu'ils sont extrêmement
exposées et qu'ils sont là pour cette
tranquillité publique
donc c'est déjà énorme de travailler sur
ce sujet là vous avez dit que vous
n'aviez aucune information sur l'
enquête mais en tant que maire est-ce
que vous pouvez avoir accès sur des
fichiers pour par exemple des fichiers
est soudé individu dangereux qui serait
sur votre territoire
non ça c'est en dehors les les on a
l'impression que le maire a tous les
pouvoirs il y a quand même des choses
qui sont bien séparés et il est
important aussi que chaque institution
soit dans ses prérogatives il n'est pas
question pour un maire en tous les cas
dans ma position à moi je ne souhaite
pas aller sur des prérogatives qui ne
nous appartiennent pas aujourd'hui nous
avons de plus en plus de transfert de
responsabilité il y en a déjà beaucoup
donc n'allons pas chercher celle dont
n'avons pas besoin pour je dirais
travailler sur le quotidien de notre
ville alors l'assaillant était un
tunisien résidant sur rambouillet depuis
inconnu des services de police et de
sécurité l'homme de 39 ans avait
régularisé ses papiers en 2019
le sénat a rendu hommage le 5 mai à la
policière tuée et son président gérard
larcher a déclaré je le cite attentats
après attentats nous avons l'impression
de répéter les mêmes mots d'assister au
même cérémonie de rencontrer les mêmes
familles dévastées par le chagrin
les mesures antiterroristes sont elles
trop laxiste et que faire alors que
faire là encore ça n'est pas à nous
maire de pouvoir
voir les dispositifs à prendre nous nous
devons appliquer comme je vous le disais
en introduction par exemple lorsque nous
avons des mesures vigipirate à mettre en
place les appliquer les mettre en place
être vigilant apprendre aussi à tous nos
agents d'être prudent parce que c'est
c'est ainsi mettre des digicodes m des
visiophone au maximum je ne peux pas
dire que pourquoi dire laxiste je ne
sais pas la preuve en est qu'aujourd'hui
il y à des attentats qui ont lieu je
sais aussi qu'il y à des attentats qui
sont des jouets parce que cela on n'en
entend pas parler non plus oui il y as
certainement à un moment donné une
réflexion plus globale à mettre en place
mais ce que je souhaite dire aussi
aujourd'hui c'est de faire extrêmement
attention à ne pas faire d' amalgame et
c'est là je pense tout le rôle d'un
maire pour qu' il reste un état
pacifique au sein d'une ville c'est à
dire bien faire la différence entre des
attentats qui sont perpétrés par des
personnes au nom d'une religion mais
finalement au nom d'une religion qui est
politique et ne pas mettre sur toute la
population musulmane entre autres la en
particulier sur cette affaire et de
jeter l'opprobre sur toute cette
population donc c'est tout l'équilibré
que nous devons trouver il ya également
les élections dans l'actualité les
municipales de 2020 ont recueilli un
taux d'abstention record à rambouillet
avec plus de 61%
pensez vous que c'est ce que ces
élections départementales et régionales
vont être un révélateur avant le rendez
vous présidentiel de 2022 concernant
l'investissement des français en
politique alors je serais tenter de vous
dire que j'ai pas de boule de cristal et
que voilà on va voir les la
participation nous
nous mettons en tous les cas en ordre de
marche déjà pour accueillir tous les
électeurs dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires possibles et je pense que ça
c'est vraiment un message à passer
en effet les municipales ont connu un
taux d'abstention entre autres sur la
ville de rambouillet qui est assez
record et parce que nous sommes plutôt
une ville qui est assez participative
normalement probablement que la crise
sanitaire a beaucoup joué
les craintes aujourd'hui nous avançons
nous sommes à 1 en deux sets de ce début
de crise et nous avons pris aussi des
habitudes et puis là nous renforçons
vraiment drastiquement toutes les
mesures sanitaires au niveau des bureaux
de vote ça c'est de notre devoir de le
transmettre dans l'ain former nos
électeurs pour que déjà cette partie
craintes sanitaires puisse ne pas être
une raison de ne pas venir voter ensuite
par rapport à la démarche du vote
je pense que il y a tout un travail
civique à refaire ça faisait partie des
thèmes de ma campagne a ramené du
civisme au niveau de la ville parce que
je pense que malheureusement les
citoyens aujourd'hui n'ont pas
conscience de la chance que nous avons
d'être dans une démocratie où nous
sommes appelés à nous exprimer et ça je
pense que c'est ce sont des choses à
remettre en place
alors peut-être manque de confiance le
monde politique a sans doute des
questions à se poser sur la façon
dont il présente des élections en ce qui
me concerne moi j'ai été élu sans
affichage politique parce que j'estime
qu'un maire et le maire de toul et de
tous les citoyens de sa ville et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que l'on
redonne l'envi à nos citoyens à nos
concitoyens d'aller s'exprimer dans les
urnes parce que c'est vraiment important
et je souhaite vraiment que pour ces
élections
et bien il y ait une mobilisation et je
pense qu'il ne faudra pas forcément
tirer des leçons parce que chaque
scrutin est différent savez vous comment
vont se passer les élections avez-vous
pris des mesures notamment sanitaires
pour accueillir les électeurs
alors oui bien sûr les mesures
sanitaires qui nous sont alors qu'ils
nous sont imposées mais dans le bon sens
du terme ça n'est pas péjoratif comme
terme sont déjà très importante
en effet il y aura le port du masque
puisque nous en sommes encore là le gel
hydroalcoolique
le fait d'être limité par en nombre de
en termes de nombre de personnes dans
les bureaux de vote
une campagne de vaccination pour les
assesseurs parce que il y à aussi
l'autre versant des élections
l'organisation est organisée avec la
présence d'assesseurs il y a les
scrutateurs le soir qui font le
dépouillement
donc il faut vraiment que ces personnes
puissent venir en toute sécurité
et puis nous nous rajoutons des choses
ça c'est au gré des municipalités nous
avons fait le choix d'acquérir des plexi
pour bien séparer et pour apporter une
sécurité tant pour les personnes qui
tiennent les bureaux de vote que aussi
pour les électeurs depuis que vous êtes
élu le pays traverse donc une crise
sanitaire social et bien plus
en vous présentant à la mairie vous ne
pouviez vous attendre à de tels
événements durant votre mandat est
également à ces attaques et bien
d'autres comment le vivez-vous
eh bien au jour le jour en assumant
cette responsabilité en étant
présente et en prenant le recul
suffisant pour rester je dirais dans un
état de calme alors de calme apparent
mais il n'empêche que il faut savoir
être mesurée lorsque l'on est maire je
n'imaginais pas un mandat aussi bousculé
je ne m'imaginais même pas mr il y a ne
serait-ce que deux ans donc vous
imaginez que pour moi ce sont beaucoup
de choses à digérer mais je suis
extrêmement heureuse du mandat que
j'assume et passionné par tout ce que
j'ai à faire et accompagner encore une
fois être à la fois accompagné les
rambolitains être accompagné par des
services parce que lorsque l'on est
maire nous ne sommes pas seuls et je
suis extrêmement aidés par des services
et quand vous me demandez comment
j'assume
justement ce mandat et bien je l'assumé
aussi beaucoup avec les services sur
lesquels je m'appuie parce qu'il ne faut
pas oublier que lorsque l'on est élu
maire nous sommes de passage nous sommes
élus pour six ans il faut vraiment
jamais l'oublier ça n'est pas une raison
pour ne mettre pour ne mettre une
politique en place que pour les six
années durant lesquelles nous allons
être à la tête de la ville
il faut penser les années futures mais
nous sommes de passage alors que nous
avons des collaborateurs qui sont là qui
sont là en permanence et qui connaissent
parfaitement la ville
donc voilà s'appuyer sur eux c'est quand
même quelque chose de très important et
puis sur une équipe
un maire n'est pas seule il y à tous les
élus qui sont autour tous mes collègues
et il est important de faire corps et
d'avancer de se faire confiance les uns
les autres
s'appuyer sur les élus s'appuyer sur vos
équipes mais aussi sur la famille
puisque pour vous la famille et sa crème
avons pu le constater lors des dernières
élections avec votre victoire
avant d'accepter d'être candidate de la
majorité sortante vol infirmière de
profession avait consulté votre famille
avant de vous lancer les familles
politiques justement deviennent de plus
en plus difficile
il à comprendre pour les français des
alliances ont réalisé entre les partis
les candidats passent d'un mouvement à
l'autre vous qui vous est présenté
justement sans étiquette malgré un
penchant vers la droite républicaine
pensez vous que la direction à prendre
pour les prochaines politiques de demain
ce serait d'être sans étiquette alors en
tous les cas au niveau local je moi
j'estime que healy a toute la légitimité
à ne pas avoir d'étiquette
parce que en effet comme je vous le
disais en tant que maire je suis mère de
tous les rangs boli temps et pas que
d'une partie de la population
j'estime de voir mon devoir est de
rassembler et d'exercer une politique
qui va concerner chacun d'entre eux les
habitants de la ville dans laquelle
j'exerce mon mandat au niveau politique
nationale il y a des questions à se
poser
je pense que par rapport à ceux au sujet
précédent sur l'abstention
il faudra sans doute tirer des leçons
justement des scrutins à venir et voir
si finalement cette désertion des
bureaux de vote est dû à des étiquettes
politiques qui n'ont plus de sens pour
les français ça c'est une vraie question
à mon niveau de mers évidemment ce n'est
pas moi qui vais tout révolutionner mais
je pense qu'en effet et je je je vois
quand même pour discuter avec
différentes personnalités politiques que
cette question taraude beaucoup de
personnes politiques et c'est sans doute
une des questions qui va falloir creuser
profondément dans les mois à venir
alors vous êtes normande de naissance et
surtout la deuxième femme à obtenir un
mandat à rambouillet après jacqueline
comme pato nôtre c'était en quarts de 47
à 83 est ce une fierté pour vous alors
oui je ne suis pas
archi féministe dans l'âme je suis
heureuse alors à voir l'héritage de
jacques l'hymne tom patenôtre et quelque
chose quand même de très important c'est
une personne qui a a été extrêmement
importante et extrêmement investi très
novatrice parce que faire de la
politique pour une femme à cette époque
là c'était quand même quelque chose de
de compliqué de qui ne faisait pas du
tout partie de la norme
j'avoue que finalement je ne me suis
jamais posé la question on m'a demandé
de prendre la succession de marc robert
comme vous le disiez j'ai du temps à
parce que j'ai demandé de la réflexion
ça n'est pas un choix que l'on fait
comme ça du jour au lendemain ça
impliquait aussi forcément la famille
parce que c'est une tâche qui demande
beaucoup de temps et puis aussi sur le
versant professionnelle parce que je ne
voulais pas non plus lâcher totalement
ma profession d'infirmière à laquelle je
suis aussi très attaché
donc ça n'est pas forcément en tant que
femme que je me suis posé la question
mais je vois et c'est très étonnant que
parmi les rambolitains certains viennent
vers moi et me disent ah on voit que
c'est une femme qui est à la tête de la
ville parce que il ya des nouveautés qui
aurait tout à fait pu être des
nouveautés du même suite à l'élection
d'un homme n'est peut-être qu'il y a une
certaine image en tous les cas pendant
la campagne
c'est vrai que sur le terrain j'ai
croisé énormément de rambolitains parce
que j'ai fait une campagne de terrain et
étonnamment on me disait souvent c'est
bien que ce soit une femme alors
revenons en aux mesures gouvernementales
à compter du 19 mai réouverture des
lieux culturels terrasse enceintes
sportives le couvre-feu sera décalée à
21h puis le 9 juin un décalage du
couvre-feu à 23h le 30 juin date prévue
du retour à la normale sous conditions
pour vous laurence trochut pour vous
excusez moi le gouvernement s'apprête il
a renouvelé sa stratégie de l'année
dernière avec une réouverture durant les
périodes estivales pour faire plaisir
aux français avant un retour aux
restrictions
alors je pense que on n'est pas là non
plus pour faire plaisir aux français
c'est à dire qu'il faut aussi que à un
moment donné la vie reprenne et là
aujourd'hui quand je j'écoute les
rambolitains et puis toutes les
personnes de mon entourage
cette crise sanitaire pèse énormément et
en allant de confinement déconfinement
en ouverture de ré refermeture on voit
bien que ça commence à peser que la vie
normale alors moi je mets des guillemets
sur vie normale parce que il va
certainement y avoir encore des mesures
à à garder ne serait ce que des gestes
barrières à un moment donné la vie doit
reprendre et si nous voulons nous
orienter vers une rentrée scolaire
prochaine
la plus normalisé possible ça ne se fera
pas du jour au lendemain
donc là nous allons entrer dans une
période où la réouverture va permettre
déjà de voir comment le virus
continue à progresser ou non nous avions
quelques craintes avec la roue la
réouverture des écoles
pour ne rien vous cacher alors c'est
compliqué c'est vrai que il y a des
classes qui ferment voire même nous
avons une école sur le rambouillet qui a
qui a dû fermer
mais petit à petit on voit bien que les
gens ressortent et puis et puis il y à
aussi l'avis du travail le télétravail
ne peut pas perdurer indéfiniment
donc je suis optimiste sur les
réouvertures dans la mesure où elles
sont vraiment bien accompagné ou les
explications sont clairement donné et où
la vaccination avance de son côté
sachant que la vaccination ne résout pas
non plus tous les problèmes justement on
va se projeter sur l'été et en était à
rambouillet aurons-nous un bel été et
quelles sont les animations l'agenda
alors oui nous aurons abel était parce
que rambouillet c'est aussi comme je le
dis la ville à la campagne
même si nous faisons partie de l'île de
france nous avons quand même cette
particularité d'être quasiment une ville
provinciale avec la forêt autour alors
les réouvertures des terrasses vont en
effet animer notre ville nous nous
sommes en train de travailler à 7 à ce
déploiement des terrasses et puis nous
cherchons à les faire d'une façon
attrayante c'est à dire avec des fleurs
enfin quelque chose qui va donner un
esprit fait dans la ville de rambouillet
au niveau de la culture il va y avoir
des choses qui sont novatrices aussi
parce que c'est la culture qui va se
déplacer vers les quartiers vers les
établissements j'en veux pour preuve que
nous allons avoir des sessions de
lecture et dans les centres de loisirs
pour les enfants mais aussi dans les
quartiers organisées avec une lecture le
matin lecture l'après midi toute une
programmation
nous avons le les musées qui
reprendre une de nos expositions phares
qui va permettre de mettre en avant une
artiste de la ville de rambouillet cette
exposition a été reportée de mois en
mois mais puisque c'est une rambo liten
et qu'on a ces oeuvres et bien lundi
neuf va être bientôt à l'honneur dans
notre ville le rambo litres a aussi qui
malgré ses mesures sanitaires prend des
rendez vous pour faire visiter et a
énormément d'activités très ludique et
qui sont extrêmement importantes et et
j'invite tous les auditeurs à prendre
rendez vous dans ce rambo litre 1 où il
y a vraiment des jeux qui permettent de
découvrir tout ce qui est autour des
cheminots de ses trains un musée qui est
dans un dans un endroit qui peut
paraître assez anonyme dans une maison
individuelle mais qui est un endroit
absolument délicieux est exceptionnel et
puis la mjc qui est en train de
travailler ludina chapeau à mettre en
place des animations musicales dans la
ville d'och où un été qui sera un été où
on en donnera envie d'aller dehors et
d'aller à la rencontre des différentes
activités culturelles en espérant avoir
le beau temps avec comme ça les gens
seront encore plus joyeux et content de
sortir si le soleil est là
alors là et le soleil sera là j'en suis
convaincu eh bien là nous aurons
vraiment gagner et nous aurons pu
rebooster en fait tout le monde pour
cette rentrée
parce que je pense que là c'est
important chacun a besoin aussi de se
nourrir de cette culture
et puis de ces animations et de cette
vie convivial qui nous manque
merci à vous véronique matillon d'avoir
participé à cet hebdo politique en
association avec tv 78
je rappelle que vous êtes maire de
rambouillet vice-présidente de la
communauté d'agglomération rambouillet
territoire en charge de l'action sociale
et de la santé mais également première
vice présidente de l'union des maires
des yvelines l'hebdo politique c'est
fini pour ce dimanche
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur internet et
l'application radio sensations
bonne soirée à tous et à dimanche
prochain pour un nouvel hebdo politique
lève tôt politique
[Musique]